and could you explain the rules of
syllabus is from maluma servoz no I
can't I've actually turned down a number
of offers of from game companies who
want to market Tsubasa I want to come up
with rules yeah for a game but you know
some things are better better suggested
than shown like it's it's long been a
rule of writing if one of your
characters is a great poet do not quote
any of his poetry unless you yourself
are a great poet which most writers are
not otherwise you'll embarrass yourself
servoz in the books is a is a war game
played overboard it has elements of
chess and elements of Stratego and
elements of various other war games but
it's a game of a great complexity it's a
game of great profundity it's a game
like chess which is a game that's you
know half a thousand years old and that
people play and analyze and go over is
it likely that any game company I
licensed the rights to develop it could
come up with a game to equal chess in
you know by working on it for a year no
they would come up with a game that
might be pleasant to play and people
would play it for a few years and
that'll be time for another game so it's
better to suggest the profundity and the
complexity and the symbolism of servoz
rather than to come up with an actual
set of rules for it good answer